Your car stopped working in an uninhabited place, and your plane was forced to land
Or trying to stay alive in the midst of an urban crash in your city.
You will need skills to continue living after losing your well-being
but how? The main necessities of survival are: water, food, housing, heating and clothing.
Let's start with water. The search for a source of clean water will be an integral part of the task
If water is found, it will not be disease-free.
You will need to boil the water for five minutes to kill the harmful bacteria
Existing toxins are probably proteins that break down at high temperatures.
You can consume water from the cactus by cutting parts of it and crushing them into a vase.
When temperatures drop, you can eat pure ice with thick ice because they are the best sources.
If you can not get fresh water you can collect dew from the loose tissue
Rainwater can be collected from leaves and cracks.
Do not waste water licking your lips. You can suck a button or pebble to overcome dry mouth and thirst.
Once you find the water, drink slowly over a long period of time.
For the body to use efficiently and will prevent nausea.
As for food, it treats insects, cockroaches, earthworms and other protein-rich organisms, vitamins and minerals
Which are important for survival.
You also have to scare the animals, especially the owls, foxes and foxes
They will leave their prey if they succeed
And then you can take it.
Lactic acid found in predatory prey may make it harsh and spoil quickly
Compared to the newly caught but when cooked directly will be fine.
After months without vitamin C you will begin to feel weak and your body is struggling to heal itself.
This is because vitamin C is an integral part of the vital processes that build collagen and structural protein that works on wound healing.
Tea making will provide you with boiled pine leaves
Vitamin C is equal to that in a glass of orange juice.
Rabbit one of the easiest animals to catch him
Because he relies heavily on camouflage, he approached him calmly as he watched him.
However you will not be able to survive relying solely on the rabbit
Because it is low in fat and therefore you need to find more fat.
Our consumption of fat comes from food such as:
Butter, milk, oil and ice cream are hard to get in the wild.
So you'll have to look hard. Some plants and berries may be fatal
So think like a squirrel and all the nuts
Walnuts are safe and rich in fat.
The bitter taste comes from organic tannins found in tea and beer.
If you boil the nut for two hours you will reduce the bitter taste
Leave it to dry or grind to become a paste and make pancakes.
All dandelion parts are edible, too.
You can also boil it to reduce its bitterness.
Maple seeds are also an amusing snack of high nutritional value
Fish intake will be nutritional values
But there are alternatives that do not need to be hunted
Seaweeds are of high nutritional value.
It can be boiled, steamed, fried or eaten fresh without cooking.
And molluscs found abundantly along the Pacific coast of North America.
The common way to cook meat is to hang a stick over the fire
But steam can be cooked by digging a hole and placing hot rocks inside and then covering them
With wet plants or seaweed
And then put the food and slowly add the pure water produces hot steam rocks.
To make heating and to ignite the fire you will need matches or lighter
But in difficult times you can hit two stones with each other to get sparks.
Keep your eyes open to find the iron perit
It is a fast-igniting metal that is extracted for its combustible properties.
Another option is safe using magnifying glasses that work well.
Once you get the sparks you will need a quick flammable material, a name called the material that ignites quickly and easily.
Examples include birch bark, dry moss, lichen, grass
Evergreen plants and bark of cedar trees.
Once it ignites, put the ends of the sticks in the fire and push them to the flame in a clear way.
This is an effective way to keep NARC burning for the longest period
Do not want to set fire to your residence for known reasons
You need proper ventilation to stop carbon monoxide poisoning
The low cave is a perfect refuge for putting the fire in the foreground at a safe distance from you to keep warm.
In the forest, breaking the tree branches to make a sloping building is also a simple and effective idea.
At a gradual downward angle to the wind
Start building the walls from the bottom up. Use the stick to make a runway around the building to drain rainwater
For a convenient arrangement, it can be filled with pine nuts, dry moss, leaves, and ferns
In the winter do not wear very warm clothes
As your body is able to adjust temperature and sweating leads to dehydration.
On your way out wear your shoes and thick woolen socks
Let your jeans be at home, you'll need a larger space around your knees for lightness.
Look for clothes that have many pockets
Preferably those that can be closed, loose cotton shirts will provide you with better protection from insects.
Use animal fat to lubricate shoes and make them water resistant,
Bird feathers can also be kept under clothing to make them warm when needed.
Now review the section and record all notes for reference when Internet use is unavailable.
good luck
And if you want to watch how some of the rich prepare for the end of the world
, Watch the second video by clicking on the screen or using the link in the description box
They are called "Bipers" and are always ready. Follow us to watch our weekly videos.
Translation team translated @Autrjim